en Haití la crisis se profundiza día a
día decenas de personas han muerto a
causa de un nuevo brote de cólera para
hacer frente a la necesidad de una
respuesta urgente médico Sin fronteras
abrieron unidades de tratamiento en
Puerto Príncipe donde han recibido
asientos de pacientes
desde el principio de octubre comenzamos
a recibir pacientes con síntomas
similares al cólera instalamos algunas
carpas para recibir pacientes y tratar
los principalmente con medidas de
hidratación recibimos alrededor de 40
personas todos los días desde el
comienzo del brote de cólera
muchos afectados son niños funcionarios
de Naciones Unidas detallaron que
100.000 menores de 5 años padecen de
desnutrición y son particularmente
vulnerables a contraer cólera
el domingo pasado cuando desperté vi que
mi hijo vomitaba tenía diarrea lo que me
obligó a llevarlo a un centro cerca de
mi casa pero no había médico fueron los
responsables de médicos Sin fronteras
quienes nos trajeron a este centro para
brindarle la atención necesaria
la actividad humanitaria se concentra en
site Soleil una de las más afectadas por
la violencia pandillera y los bloqueos
la presencia de estos actores criminales
impide la normal llegada de asistencia
extranjera formando bloqueos en
terminales de combustible ante los
planes de aumentar los costos y
generando perturbaciones en la
distribución de alimentos y de agua
potable
Haití se enfrenta a una catástrofe
humanitaria la seguridad alimentaria en
Haití está empeorando el informe de
clasificación integrada de las fases de
la seguridad alimentaria muestran la
gravedad y el alcance de la inseguridad
alimentaria hay 4,7 millones de personas
en Haití que enfrentan una inseguridad
alimenta aguda 1,8 millones de ellos
enfrentan niveles de emergencia
ante la precaria situación del país más
pobre de la región el Primer Ministro
Ariel Henry solicitó asistencia militar
extranjera para hacer frente a las
pandillas países como Canadá y Estados
Unidos ya anunciaron el envío de
vehículos blindados para la policía
haitiana